this living laboratory of evolution  helped to inspire Charles Darwin and  continues to offer a unique opportunity  to explore a pristine natural ecosystem  the Galapagos Islands are located 620  miles or 1,000 kilometres from the South  American mainland but a world apart from  anywhere else on earth  the archipelago and its surrounding  waters located where three ocean  currents converge are famed for the  unique animal species found nowhere else  on earth including marine iguanas giant  tortoises flightless cormorants and a  diverse variety of finches the islands  have two airports Isla baltra and Isla  San Cristobal which are serviced by  regular flights from mainland cities  Quito and Guayaquil  as water temperatures change and seasons  shift different types of Wildlife become  more or less plentiful so it's worth  keeping a must-see species list in mind  when planning your itinerary  [Music]